hey everyone davolo here and in today's
video we are jumping into a new series
that believe it or not up until two
months ago I hadn't even watched let
alone read but after smashing out the
series I actually don't know what the
hell I was smoking because holy it was
some Pure Old School gas so yes finally
we are diving into bleach and the
literally insane Thousand-Year blood War
like oh my Lord this whole Arc is just
pure Insanity with fights after fight
after fight after fight to the point
where you actually wonder how it could
ever possibly end the constant breakdown
and photorization of characters I looked
at is Immortal and just purely
Untouchable as freaking mental so here
today I plan to make my way through all
of the greatest fights and just pure
beatdowns throughout the 250 plus
chapter Arc but just before we do get
into the video if you are new around
here I want to watch more stuff just
like this but for a multitude of
different series then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and also be sure
to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with pushing my content
to a bunch of new amazing weaves but
anyway enough of there let's finally get
into the first major battle that takes
Place throughout the early stages of the
Thousand-Year blood War so initially
after ichigo's first battle up against
that dude who legit just showed up
inside of his room looking like he
wanted to lay someone out on the bed a
random set of events happen that
resulted Nell and peshe falling from the
sky and the human world and informing
our boy that hueco Mondo has been
defeated honestly you know I'm just so
confused how they even made it into the
real world from hueco Mundo so feel free
to let me know down in the description
below because I'm still currently like
reading my way through the Thousand Year
blood War so I don't have a complete
understanding on how everything works
yet and you know of course reading
bleach for the first time and
understanding these names is probably
the hardest thing I've had to do for a
little while here going from Japanese to
Spanish to German names is blowing my
mind at some points but anyway anyway
after conversating with them and getting
a rundown of the events with Harry Bell
and how she was defeated big udahara
appears on the windowsill looking
absolutely chill asking if he'd like to
organize a little outing to Quaker Mundo
for the group so well hopefully that
brings everyone up to date with what
happens in between the two fights with
Ichigo and stuff there are some the
stuff that goes down in the soul society
and everything but if you guys want me
to go over say the fall of Serie Yeti
then make sure you let me know in the
comment section below and I'll go over
the entire destruction of the Soul
Society in one video alone anyway after
organizing this little outing everyone
which includes the real life Chad Chad
appreciate like remember that ranker
from way back during like episode 200
and something everyone's favorite age
regressor now anyway udahada and of
course our substitute spiky head Soul
Reaper Ichigo fall into hueco Mundo and
take cover behind some Rebel to avoid
being noticed one of the wandan Reich
look in the direction thinking he heard
something but another tells him that
it's frankly impossible as everyone
around those parts have been killed or
are with them now as Ichigo and the
others briefly discussed how they were
not noticed udahada knows that they've
been unnoticed must be because they know
there are no living Hollows or Iran car
remaining in the area as they look
around the surroundings noting the
brutality of the situation pishe tells
them how all the hollows in a ranca were
unable to stand up to the wandan reich's
previously unseen Powers they live with
no leader and no means of a way to fight
back the only possible choice they had
was to frantically run for their lives
after Ichigo asks the holy-fied Barney
where there are many members of the
group would be taken pishi tells him
that they will be taken to a camp which
you know like oh my Lord the whole like
Nazi vibe from this wandan boys group
any mention of a campus just reason for
an investigation in freaking my eyes
anyways anyways he explains that at the
camp they will be divided into groups a
process which decides who will be killed
and who will be forced into serving the
quincies prompting Ichigo to not even
let him finish explaining and go and
rescue them as Fisher expressed a
surprise at ichigo's abrupt decision to
save all of the other trapped around car
on the way to Dondo Chaka the others who
are following home note ichiko's wish to
save even his former enemies is exactly
something that he would do nearby and
chilling like he absolutely owns the
place the general hunt Commander kilgate
Opie commands his subordinates to line
up the survivors to figure out whether
they deserve to be taken back to the
emperor after explaining the sadistic
intentions of how he's literally going
to stab each of them to death a random
aranca steps up and tries to reason with
him but Opie doesn't even listen as he
simply stabs him in the gut with his
spear killing him and then starts off
killing several more around her as an
example to the others that this is how
their lives will end until 200 figures
who turn out to be Lolly and Melanie two
of eisen's old Sims launched a surprise
attack on him after disarming his spear
they then try to go on a spiel about how
they won't be defeated by simple minion
like him only to then be taken off guard
as he easily subdues both of them by
shooting Melanie in the chest and
backhanding Lolly onto the Sandy ground
below walking away kelgate tells his men
to not kill the girls as their leader is
looking for any courageous fools even
still he just walks away underwhelmed
with the entire situation suddenly
though a few of his men are instantly
killed as a large spinning projectile is
sent hurling towards him turning in time
though the stern router easily manages
to block the object and stop it in its
tracks asking who's there the banging
and beautiful checks from the trees
Beast ears make their appearance atop a
pile of rubble not gonna lie it's just
too dope to see all these old characters
who I honestly thought die throughout
the karakura Town conflict come back and
re-implement themselves into the story
in a different way now almost with a
complete role reversal from how things
were like last time we saw them they
were the aggressors trying to take over
an area and this time they were
literally fighting for their home and
survival but I absolutely love the
parallel between the two as the three
Iran car take on the first jagdamir
Ichigo notices the large explosions in
front of him from on his shoulder like a
pit and utterly taking him by surprise
now reveals that it's a riyatsu of the
tree's best ears or three breaths up in
front of them she says that they are
super strong and should be able to
destroy the enemy Force before they even
arrive over in the battle the three
paves easily managed to kill a bunch of
kilgate's photo subordinates before
taking on the captain himself facing
them kill gate offers them one piece of
advice and advises the girls they
surrender immediately if they do this
they will be able to become allies and
reunite with their beloved Harry Belle
his deathly thought of being taken
lightly by the adversary the girls erupt
with anger and re-initiate the fight
with a disappointed kill gay close by as
Ichigo sees another massive explosion
Nell tells them that there would be no
point in interrupting the beat down
however as they arrive Ichigo is
instantly stunned to see all three Iran
car have been defeated by a single
person noticing ichigo's arrival kill
gate cheekly states that the Shinigami
has arrived and they certainly have a
lot of visitors today still holding on
to ichigo's shoulder Nell is shocked to
see that the three breaths were defeated
standing opposite them kilgate comments
on how rare it is to see a Shinigami
with an Iran cut on his shoulder however
he tells Ichigo he knows exactly who he
is I don't know how it's possible but
somehow Ichigo has a big brain IQ and
after recalling his previous encounter
with ibun and the human world Ichigo
states that it wouldn't be much of a
surprise for them to know all about him
kilga explains to him that ichigo's
details were included and the
information passed down directly to
everyone via their Master it stated that
he is a notable threat to be eliminated
with the highest priority due to being
considered a special War potential not
really concerned with the student
monologue though asigo jumps down to
confront him when all of a sudden kilgay
and his men surround him with a high
speed movement that isn't shinpo or
sunido either initially confused on how
they move so quick Ichigo recognizes
their movement as the Heron kyaku as
he's seen Ishida using it in the past
before wore kilgate's three Associates
who surrounded our spiky head Wrangler
then fire Adam with their bows but as he
charges out of the smoke covered area
completely unarmed he asks if they are
really Quincy's asking if each got
really charged into battle without a
proper understanding of who he was going
up against kilgame knows that Ichigo
must have suspected it but wasn't
exactly able to confirm it Judah was
lack of evidence during his Spirit
weapon which is just clean as looking
saber by the way kilgate tells Ichigo
that he will give him his answer he is
indeed correct as they are the very same
Quincy he knows so well which is like yo
what do you what do you mean by that
dude as you know as I've said I'm still
reading my way for this Arc here so
there are times where I'm honestly just
as confused as all of you and damn it
you get to find out what they could
possibly mean of these cheeky lines here
and there anyways anyways skipping away
momentarily over to the actual
Powerhouse of this series then Master
himself beg your walk which I'm not even
sure if I see correctly as informed that
the notable threat Ichigo Kurosaki has
an infiltrated hueco Mondo and is now
engaged in a battle against the general
Commander kilgay op pleased with a tune
of events your walk begins to leave
confused though as the subordinates look
on they ask where he is going to which
he States it should be obvious as he is
now heading to the soul Society he
doesn't know why Ichigo is here but
states that this is the perfect time to
go and bring the soul Society to its
knees commanding his menacing word of
this change to the sternverter you walk
states that the wandan Reich invasion of
the Soul Society begins immediately back
in the battle now and fire any burst of
arrows from a saber at Ichigo kilgate
states that they all have been marked
then asks what happened to Ichigo as he
shouldn't be finished already randomly
ichiko zambakto falls through the smoke
and stabs into the ground below
perplexing a slightly confused kill gay
before he hears Ichigo call out as he
smoked from kilgai's Attack clears
Ichigo looking like an absolute baller
with the arrows fighting him now being
held in his hand states that it is odd
because his boy udyu told him the
Quincy's only ever use bows catching
kilgate off guard Ichigo shoots down and
Returns the arrows right back at his
opponent causing a mass of smoke and
sand to be kicked up by the beam he then
returns to the ground and grabs the
zombucked toe then noticing orahime and
Chad finally catching up he literally
just bursts nail towards the door
telling them to take care of her for now
noticing several more arrows beaming
towards him he counters them by quickly
firing off a gitsuka 10 show which
absorbs the arrows and continues on its
way towards the Quincy as the attack
clears kilgo trying to pull off their
evil villain type reappearance emerges
completely unharmed he states that he
feels ashamed at the inadequacy of his
own lack of skills giving out Ichigo
easily dodged repelled and even threw
back a helic fell with his bare hands
asking if Quincy arrows will have weird
names like that one Ichigo then goes on
to say that his arrows were more
powerful than ishidas though slightly
bemused by ichigo's mentioning of uriu
kilke asks Ichigo if he is referring to
uruashida which is like yo is or do you
gonna pop off later on in the arc or is
he something sneaky with him going on
behind the scenes new anyway bro let's
see that they know odiu Ichigo asks him
who the hell they even are kilgo says
that it's strange that Ichigo thinks
that uru's healing for Fel is weaker
than his as that possibly cannot be true
when Ichigo questions what this could
possibly mean kill gay realizing that he
is overspoken says speech is silver and
silence is golden then sheathing is
saber he knows that is much more info to
report back on to his majesty causing
Ichigo to ask who this mysterious person
could be that kilge says answering that
question would be utterly pointless as
now he has just received orders from
that mysterious leader to defeat Ichigo
here and now with all of his strength
raising his hand near his face kilgate
tells Ichigo to please watch free master
have at least heard of the power he is
about to use the Quincy let's still
taking off his right glove like it's
some form of Russian doll revealing
another one below it he then activates
the technique causing a massive beam of
ethereal blue light to extend shooting
up into the ear suddenly it shatters
with kilger emerging below revealing his
new mystical looking form that seemingly
made up of reishi standing above Ichigo
he states that the proper name of the
form he is currently using is known as
the Quincy ball standuke which for all
my poor English people however like
myself who aren't the center of
attention with their own language and
are utterly confused with like what's
going on with some of these German names
here pretty much the elite still kind of
like stands for last style and this
Quincy Vol standard literally means
Quincy complete so like the final or
complete form so I hope that solves some
confusion at least anyways anyways from
a distance and looking at kilge orahime
finds it odd that she cannot sense any
reishi shock waves or riyatsu from the
Quincy as he approaches Ichigo kilgate
asks feel as pulsating power which is
like chill bro what the is
pulsating quickly moving behind Ichigo
and then catching him off guard kilgo
saves it's the power of the one who will
punish him remembering a conversation he
had with kisuke udahada who told him
about the Quincy lit still Ichigo
wonders if kilgate is using this power
now as he presses the Shinigami he
notices ichigo's confusion over whether
or not he's using lit still because of
this he explains to him that they are
not the same leaked still is a relic of
a past which died out over 200 years ago
because of its inherent weakness the
only one still foolish enough to use it
was a shida as he refuses to go along
with the progress and achievements his
race have made kilgate then strikes at
Ichigo swinging his blade down however
Ichigo easily manages to block the
attack with a zumpuck toe and tells
kilgay that he doesn't care about their
history but is relieved that ashida
hasn't transformed into a creepy form
like his own taunting him Ichigo tells
kilge that his Blade's Edge is weakening
before firing a massive gituga 10 show
directly at him as the attack flies
forth Ichigo realizes that kill game
wasn't even phased as he managed to
instantly appear before him asking if he
is ever considered the concept of aiming
as attacks which is pretty
brutal cursing asigo pulls back as kilge
who's still taunting him says Amy
wouldn't even help or he has no
weaknesses at all asking if Ichigo
called him creepy just before kilgate
raises his right arm and declares his
reaction is the proper one for a
barbaric shinig Army as to face the
ultimate enforcers of all that is holy
and righteous must be an abhorrent and
terrifying sight pointing his saber into
the sky kilgate then begins to suck up a
large amount of reishi from the
surrounding environment standing nearby
and completely helpless to the situation
orahime watches in disbelief is her
ability is absorbed however Che corrects
her observation as he notices that
everything made up of reishi has been
absorbed directly into the Quincy which
in turn also answers orahime's question
on why he wasn't able to sense any
reishi shockwaves earlier for Quincy's
absorb ratio instead of a messy nerds
having gathered sufficient reishi for
his technique kilge raises his right arm
and tells Ichigo to prepare to feel the
power of His volstanding the skill watch
I'm not even sure if I said right as the
B sounds like a V by the way and the
English translation it's called the
justice of God so it's super interesting
to see this new lot try and take on more
of a Godly stance than say this
Shinigami who are literally like the
death gods in this universe anyways
anyways before he could use this
technique though the absorbed reishi is
completely shattered in the palm of his
hand and he has since shooting into a
pile of rubble by someone who I
literally thought I would never see
again behind him and still looking just
as jacked as he was before Yamamoto set
disaster in the last battle aeon makes
his reappearance having actually
sustained some damage Now kill gay
wonders what the actual aeon even
is nearby and still recovering from
almost dying the Tris Bestia scream out
repeating the earlier warning to not
underestimate them and ordering aeon to
attack and kill that pompous four-eyed
monkey aeon momentarily turns to his
creators prompting the confused girls to
ask what he's even looking at and sung
sun to wonder if he's actually worried
about them seeing this Apache like the
forward-going one she is tells aeon not
to worry about them and instead to
defeat the enemy with this aeon looked
at a freaking loud ass Roar and bursts
into rage this causes Ichigo and the
others to wonder what the hell aeon even
is as obviously they never witnessed the
last time he was summoned Apache
explains to them that aeon is a monster
created from the left arms and since
they aren't enemies this time she warns
the other group to not get any way if
they don't want to be killed as aeon
can't even determine friend from foe
back in the battle as the Mindless Beast
rushes towards kilgay who takes up a
Battle Stance and simply denies the fact
that a monster like him could either
possibly defeat his volstanding yet as
per usual aeon is just something else
and easily lends a right punch in
kilgay's face sitting him shooting up
into the sky aeon doesn't give up though
and chases his opponent down instantly
tearing off his wings and smashing him
into the ground over and over and oh
over again seemingly killing the
helpless Quincy aeon thinking close his
Rampage by slamming kilgate back into
the ground leaving half of his corpse
already buried beneath the Sands of
hueco Mondo happy with their Pet's work
Apache decides to come up for a closer
look and almost rubs in the fact that
they silly old Quincy underestimated
them she expresses how impressed she is
with kilgate's durability considering he
is still in one piece after being
smashed up by aeon however our armor
saranka is taken by surprise as all of a
sudden she stared through the chest by
kilgate saber as he slowly stands back
up Pauline his broken ass body out of
the sand he mentions that they were
given no info on aeon in their reports
snapping his neck back into place he
states he wouldn't existing word to his
majesty that the blood should be
strengthened which I think is some sort
of blood infusement that he's getting
from the big man himself but I ain't
really too sure yet I would love to know
like your thoughts on the abilities of
Quincy's in general and your favorite
fights and throughout like this massive
Arc that you want me to cover in the
coming future anyways anyways kill game
notes that before he does report back he
will have to hurry within defeats and
begins activating a new technique
standing there he tells the monster that
he will be the first to die but corrects
himself and saves that no he will
actually be the first to live seeing the
danger of kilgo's technique Mila Rose
warns aeon not to attack but the warning
comes too late as the brainless monster
charges adequency once again standing
there helpless the girls are shocked to
see aeon's body slowly begin to break
down and be absorbed and to kill gay
slowly walking towards them he reveals
the abilities name as clavieri which is
literally German for slavery in Japanese
for Holy slave and explains the ability
as it Quincy's basic ability to gather
reishi in the highest degree allowing
the user to enslave it to their will he
admits that he didn't want to use it as
it makes his holy form become tainted
with evil from such Wicked beasts seeing
this Mila Rose and sang San decide to
retreat with a party to orahime
underneath the Dome of sang-san's muda
but kilgay who noticed is that they were
able to hide themselves find and absorbs
the Dome before continuing to literally
rip the freaking reishi of his
opponent's bodies as if this dude is
like literally tearing their skin off as
the steroided up Mania tells those below
him to hurry up and die he surprisingly
interrupted by Ichigo who having just
activated his Bankai attacks him and
proclaims that he can stop this new
ability of his all he has to do now is
destroy the Halo floating above the
Quincy's head instantly taking the
offensive Ichigo begins to pressure kill
gay who attempts to try and seal
ichigo's Bankai using a special
Medallion finding The Medallion does
absolutely nothing though he'll get
curses as he takes a direct hit from
ichigo's Bankai moving back in an
attempt to get away kilgo recalls how he
did receive data on how they could not
middle ice his Bankai but nothing else
and that was the only issue he wonders
how he has been so easily overpowered
despite using his ultimate ability and
absorbing aeon Ichigo then appears in
front of him again and slashes him
sitting in the bulked up Quincy shooting
into the ground below and suddenly
getting back out from the HUD though and
exiting the dust clouds kill gay then
prepares to fire a barrage of arrows
towards the Shinigami but as he does so
Ichigo easily repels them all while they
get took a 10 show then commenting on
how the last 34 tried joink in his
Bankai as well he asks why it is that
they are also set on trying to steal
away Barn Kai's not seen any reason as
to why he should answer this question
though he'll get notes to himself that
ichigo's power is dangerous but his
speed is the main concern thinking about
his situation he contemplates on how
exactly he's supposed to defeat this man
in order to react to ichigo's high speed
he must keep his blood VNA at full power
but while he's doing this his unable to
use his blue art Erie so he literally
cannot defeat Ichigo as attack him
without his blue art is useless against
one who is using Bankai as he considers
calling for backup his thoughts are
instantly interrupted by Ichigo who asks
that they are instead afraid of their
Bankai and that's why they are trying to
seal them rowled up by this kilge stands
back up and is about to get halfway
through declaring the Von didn't like
fear nothing but it's absolutely
blindsided as he is shot clean through
the chest by udahada who is standing
nearby on a pile of rubble after
thanking Ichigo for giving him the
sneaky opportunity to land an easy final
blow he tosses Ichigo one of them
clapped our soul Reaper flip phones and
explains to him that this situation is
already extremely urgent so he must
hurry to the soul Society immediately he
then proceeds to open a gargant her
directly behind him and explains that
aeon will explain the details to him
while he travels towards the soul
Society Ichigo rushes through the
gargant her as a con informs him of the
severity of the situation the casualties
and the uncertainty of the whole
conflict going down inside of the Soul
Society Akon tells Ichigo about the
wandan Reich being able to steal Bankai
because captains from the 2nd 6th 7th
and 10th have all had their Bankai
stolen jumping into the conversation
urduhada who's like hacked in on his
computer thing says that he can give
them a bit more info on the surrounding
enemy's abilities he explains these
Quincy seem to possess three main
abilities now they should be aware world
the first which is Quincy volstanding or
the Quincy complete form produces the
most obvious and striking change to the
fighting capabilities the second is an
ability the Quincy referred to as blat
he says this seems to involve
manipulating the flow of the spirit
particles through their blow to boost
both the defensive and defensive Powers
however this ability does have one major
flaw as it is impossible to activate
both the defensive and defensive
capabilities at the same time so they
need to use this to their advantage in
future battles finally the third ability
one that seems to Grant Quincy's the
ability to steal or appropriate Barn
cars having gained the recently defeated
kilgaze Medallion udahada says that he
intends to figure out how this ability
works but what's currently most
important is that they are unable to
steal ichigo's Bankai and his alone
nearing the end of his journey Ezio
suddenly sees a blue beam of energy
shoot past him that reaches the exit
first and stitches it closed which
causes him to ask you to harder what the
hell just happened back in Waco Mondo
and shared or find themselves taken by
surprise as they are hit multiple times
so I kill Gay's arrows like the arrows
are literally rip parts of their bodies
off it's mental the Quincy who's managed
to somehow stand back up after using
another new ability called ranso 10 guy
fires off another shot through the
gargantu directly at Ichigo not in the
attack Ichigo turns in time and blocks
her but is somehow quickly immobilized
and imprisoned as the ability seems to
turn into a cage around him screaming
and laughing like an actual freaking
psycho kilke says that he was so close
to being able to make it back and fight
but now he will have to wait helplessly
in his dark cage in watch as the sole
Society is destroyed stuck inside of his
cage Ichigo mix cut after cut in an
attempt to escape but it's all to no use
hearing a Khan try to communicate with
him through the phone he tries to
respond but no one is able to hear him
at all as he sits there trying to take
all the information in he notices that
he cannot hear anything but screams and
explosions through the device now after
a second later he realizes that he
started to hear more than just the
people instead of the research institute
now as literally the plays from everyone
around the sole society and their own
individual battles hearing that people
believe that Ichigo will come to save
them he tries over and over and over
again to break out of his prison but
finds all of his attempts utterly futile
back with kilgay he notes how hard
Ichigo is trying to break out but says
that it's utterly pointless streaming
out he states that the letter he was
granted by his majesty was Jay and he
refers to himself as kill gay Opie the
jail and no one will ever escape the
prison he weaves turning towards chaired
in orahime the slowly deflating Quincy
states that he better eliminate the rest
of them before the power he absorbed
fully leaves him however before he can
do so the dude is utterly disrespected
and sharted all over as he has cut in
half and killed by completely unknown
but oh my Lord this guy must be a
freaking insanely powerful individual
like even case guys like holy not
this dude but anyway guys I'm still
extremely sick and like am completely
unable to get on cam at the moment
because I look completely utterly
terrible but enough of that I want to
know what you guys thought about this
fight here specifically and what fights
you think I should go over like in
anticipation for the fights being
released in the manga and the up and
coming months but anyway anyway enough
of that if you guys have enjoyed this
video and want to check out more stuff
and get earlier access to videos before
they do release then be sure to check
out my patreon which I will leave a link
to down in the description but you know
as per usual if you guys are new around
here and want to keep up to date with
the latest like Manga and Anime explain
type content then make sure you hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with pushing my stuff to a
bunch of new amazing people but anyway
enough of that for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and I
will see you all in April bye